an actress who says she was fired from
the hit CBS show bull after accusing the
star of harassment is speaking out for
the first time writing in The Boston
Globe Eliza Dushku claims that actor
Michael Weatherly and CBS retaliated
against her for simply asking to do her
job without relentless sexual harassment
the New York Times revealed last week
Dushku and CBS settled for nine and a
half million dollars
Jericka Duncan is here with why the
actress is telling her story now
Jericka good morning good morning some
very disturbing details in that Boston
Globe article Eliza Dushku says she
declined to talk to the New York Times
because she wanted to honor the terms of
her confidential settlement agreement
but she says after Michael Weatherly
tried to deflect deny and then spin what
happened to her she decided to come
forward I'm certainly here for you are
you actress Eliza Dushku says when she
was hired to appear on the hit CBS show
bull the network expressed its intent to
make her a series regular with an option
for up to six seasons we've got a
problem
what's that but Dushku would appear for
just three episodes after she claims the
show star Michael Weatherly had her fire
on Wednesday in a column in her hometown
paper The Boston Globe Dushku says
whether Lee subjected her to daily
undeniably demeaning conduct that
included going out of his way to
humiliate her constant name-calling and
making a remark to her about having a
threesome you have no idea how much
trouble hearing
you ready after weeks of allegedly
enduring Weatherly's harassment Dushku
says she decided to confront him but
within 48 hours she claims showrunner
Glenn Gordon Caron wrote her off bull so
all those people are gonna listen to my
arguments that is the idea
Dushku settled with the network earlier
this year for nine point five million
dollars roughly what she would have made
as a series regular but she says that
was only after it was revealed some of
Weatherly's harassment was captured on
CBS's own video tape recordings I
actually do believe that this is an idea
worth fighting for Dooku is also now
pushing back at criticism she had a
quote humor deficit something she claims
Weatherly had complained about I did not
overreact she said I took a job and
because I did not want to be harassed I
was fired bull showrunner Glenn gordon
karen declined our request for comment
but he told the new york times last week
the decision to induce coos run had
nothing to do with her experiences on
set Michael Weatherly has not gotten
back to us but he told the New York
Times when Dushku confronted him he was
mortified apologized and denied pushing
for her removal CBS declined to comment
but last week said in a statement while
we remain committed to a culture defined
by a safe inclusive and respectful
workplace our work is far from done
that's a true statement yeah a lot of
work to be done here at this network
thank you